hello welcome to waterpark distributed
patient actors versus the pandemic my
name is brian hunter
it's a joy to be here today to talk
about some of my team's research so
we've been off on this journey
with this research journey which led to
a product with an unusual architecture
that's out doing good in the world
so
i'm an enterprise fellow at hca
healthcare and hca is big
so hca owns and operates 186 hospitals
around 2000 surgery centers freestanding
ers and clinics
i have 275 000 colleagues out there that
can send me emails
uh with 32 million patient encounters
each year a lot of people truly depend
on us getting things right and so
that begins
in 2017 was presented with this research
challenge
uh where within the integration
enterprise integration team
and the challenge was given all the data
and the erlang vm what good could we do
could we improve patient outcomes
could we help our caregivers our nurses
our doctors
could we give our hospitals a better
footing in the event of disasters or a
pandemic
so
secondarily we had this idea that we
wanted to be able to bring some joy to
i.t and so for me dev joy
is when you can be productive and when
you have low friction ways to do
important work
biz joy is about faster delivery times
and lowering risk and uncertainty
in projects
and for ops if you have observable fault
tolerant systems
with
stress-free failure models that's going
to provide some ops joy and so we worked
hard at all these
so the years experimentation proofs and
research they seeded the seeded several
projects and one of those is project
waterpark
so to help patients and caregivers
and all of our it friends one of the
things we had to do is we had to be
highly available and so highly available
is subjective and so we went with the
more objective number and said we have
to be continuously available we can
never go down and that was an initial
goal
we wanted to make it really easy for
teams around the company to push data to
waterpark and subscribe to data from
waterpark whatever tools they came to to
discourage data hoarding make it easier
to
to go to the right place instead of
doing the wrong thing
and then we also we wanted to create a
place where experiments could happen
where we could have these fast cheap low
risk uh ground for experiments
and we also wanted to shine we wanted to
provide an example in the company of how
software could be built
and so that was this uh these particular
goals within waterpark
so let's get a view of what waterpark is
so we run on a cluster of servers
data comes in
and some data we just route straight
back out
and other data we transform we map
reduce or we change
and then other data other bits of data
other signals are generated entirely
within water park so off of all these uh
disparate streams of data we infer
meaning and we create new signals that
come out of water park
so water park it also it plays a lot of
bases and so we see here integration
engine we're an integration agent we're
a streaming system a distributed
database a content delivery network a
cache a queue a complex event processor
and a function as a service platform
so by implementing from scratch and
elixir the minimum set the minimal set
of features that we needed from say a
cache or a queue meant we didn't have to
take hard dependencies on those things
and so waterpark doesn't use a
distributed database like react or
cassandra
it is a database a distributed round ram
based database
and so investing a few months
in building tailor-fit subsets of the
features that we truly needed
to do things let us avoid dependencies
and dependencies even if they're free
aren't really free
so our deployment and failure models are
now our own we don't have to take on
properties of other systems
and that has let us
be zero downtime since we went to
production 18 months ago
thank you for that
okay as uh virtuous as wheel reinvention
can be
uh we have the carl sagan here um you
have to decide if you're inventing a
wheel reinventing a wheel or if you're
reinventing the universe and it's
important to distinguish the two
so we decided uh with our stack here we
weren't going to go off and smell ore
and make new chips and build our own
hardware we said nope
and so we went with commodity 1u servers
we tried to pick servers that were easy
to get and also that would fail as a
unit so they don't have shared storage
or any fancy features in them these are
just boxes with drives one used so that
they fail as a unit and other things
don't cause them to fail and and all of
our failures contained within that one
piece of steel
and we didn't ride a language or an
operating system either we did choose a
less conventional operating system we
chose the erlang vm
and so on a single commodity server we'd
run millions of active processes massive
concurrency out here
and these processes the asteroid
processes they auto balance across the
cores on the server
and we get soft real time without doing
anything special we don't really think
about this it just comes as part of this
operating system that we're using the
erlang vm
and there's no such thing in our world
as memory locks or threads i think it's
maybe a story that other language
developers
use to scare children or something but
uh but we don't have that and so talking
to an actor running in waterpark or
running on the erlang vm
it doesn't matter it's as simple to talk
to one locally
across the cluster as it is one locally
and there's just no difference here and
so all of those special purpose things
that came in the airline vm is a special
purpose operating system and its special
purpose is around fault tolerance
concurrency and distribution and the
actor model and it fit our needs
so the actor model let's take a quick
peek at it
so it's introduced by carl hewitt and
crew back in 73
and it's a model of concurrent
computation inspired by physics
in the model actors are this fundamental
element and when actors receive messages
they can make local changes they can
create more actors they can send
messages or they can figure out what
they're going to how they're going to
respond to the next message that comes
in we'll see a bit about that with a
universal server that we'll talk about
later
so
it would be a good idea for us to take a
quick primer i'm going to try to keep
this short about what the erlang vm is
so that it doesn't feel like a bunch of
magic that i'm talking about later
so every
actor in erlang vm
this operating system has
some props and so we have memory
and
each actor has its own dedicated
isolated block of memory
and it starts off tiny two kilobytes on
a 64-bit machine
and inside of that we have a stack and a
heap
and as our actors as they run and they
grow and they accumulate state
the state the memory grows following the
fibonacci series
and when that memory is no longer needed
well we have a garbage collector and so
each individual process that's running
so again hundreds of thousands of these
things running on a server each one of
them gets their own isolated dedicated
garbage collector now let that thing
sink in for just a second to think about
what we have here we have this
this language or this platform this
operating system that only runs
functional programming languages
all these languages
take immutability seriously you can't
mutate state
the process is you can't share memory
you can't touch memory from another
process you're the only one that's ever
touched it and
so
this is not a bad place to be a garbage
collector it's the easiest gc job in the
world to be an erlang garbage collector
and out of this we get these soft
real-time tiny deterministic gcs here
you don't have to stop the world gcs
like you would have on some other
platforms
each actor also gets a mailbox
and this is the only way the process can
talk to other things in
other actors or even to the environment
file io is actually done through talking
through the mailbox you can't do
anything other than talk through the
mailbox in erlang or elixir
and so
it's lonely being
a process or being an actor
and so
and this final box here links and
monitors
so if you would like to know if another
process out somewhere on the cluster
crashes
you can be notified you can ask the
operating system they're laying vm for
this and it'll tell you and you have two
options of doing this you can create a
link which is like a death pact you say
i
if if you die i'm going with you and if
i die you're going with me too by the
way so this is the thelma and louise and
so if we
have another option it's less intense
and it's called monitors and this is
more like reading the obituaries we want
to know when you die we care about that
but we don't want to go with you and so
built on these two primitives we have
these things in erlang vm and otp called
supervision trees that let us recover
from failure really easily and if a
group of things need to all fail if
something goes weird like you call tech
support and they say ah reboot your
computer and you do and all the
processes bounce and come back up and
everything's healthy well that's where
the idea of links come in
so let's take a quick look at scheduling
on the vm
we have a cpu core and we have a single
scheduler then
and so you can think of a program as a
stream of operations the early vm
scheduler gives each actor process a
chance to run about 2 000 or run exactly
2 000 operations and then immediately
moves on to the next active process
and it gets 2000 and so on and there's
no way that any actor can be a hog it
can't take more than it's 2000 it
immediately says preemptive scheduling
and there are no hogs and the context
switching is almost zero between these
processes
so it's just buttery smooth soft
real-time processing that we get here
and we have two cores we get two
schedulers and we go from concurrency to
concurrency and parallelism here we have
two things actually running at once
and so on on waterpark our 1u servers
they have 56 logical cores and so in
addition to our hundreds of thousands of
processes running our millions of
processes in that concurrency we
actually have 56 things truly running in
parallel at any one moment and this is
all handled by this operating system so
hopefully that gives you an idea of why
we went this route
and so now we can talk about healthcare
so
we wanted to
have a digital twin of every patient
an actor process per patient not a
database row per patient
so typically in healthcare a patient is
represented as a moment in time snapshot
of data
so rows json whatever on disk typically
and so most systems they read patient
data and they perform work based on
these current values and they flush the
memory buffers like a goldfish and then
they move on to the next data without
any idea of what just happened
waterpark we model each patient actor is
a long-running patient actor so these
patient actors they represent are
dedicated to this one human and they run
from pre-admit to discharge
for weeks
sometimes
well actually always always for weeks
and sometimes for months uh depending on
if we have a really sick patient the
patient actor will be running for a long
long time so a patient actor is not
limited to the data the latest hl7 it
holds every hl7 message in the events
that led to that current state and so
this could be thousands and thousands of
messages
there's id in healthcare called the long
shift and so you all probably know
nurses and doctors and so nurses they
often work these 12-hour shifts and it's
to provide continuity of care to
patients and to reduce the frequency of
dangerous handoffs
and this statement from
the joint commission is kind of the why
of this why caregivers work long shifts
because eighty percent of medical errors
happen in the handoffs in the transition
of care
the things the tacit knowledge that
wasn't passed along that wasn't charted
and so it's dangerous these handoffs and
so as a result this whole industry
people work longer hours just to have
one less of those a day
so patient actors we extend this long
shift idea to provide continuity of care
for our clinical systems
so we're not going to be goldfish that's
going to have a transition every every
message we're going to we're going to
have continuity of care across the actor
it gives us better context and awareness
of the full patient visit
so this awareness enables real-time
notifications and alerts based on days
or weeks of events transfers drugs
administered lab results procedures and
so on
so let's have a little bit of a
visualization of this and so we have
here in a facility we have two patients
and
we receive patients as hl7 messages and
we'll take a peek at that what those
look like in a bit
and as these hl7 messages come in they
have information about what patients
tied in there and so when they hit water
park we spin up a patient actor if we
don't have one for that patient so that
actor spins up on the cluster somewhere
and we store that admit we process it we
do whatever we're going to do with it
and we store the message also
and then another message comes in for
that same patient it accumulates
this other patient we spin up that actor
and so on and so we see this transcript
building up off of these messages
these maybe are days apart these
messages
so hl7 i told you we'd see it so there
it is this is a tiny little hl7 message
you can find this one on wikipedia
there's an article
to make it slightly easier to read i've
bolded the segment headers and put some
space in there
but we can walk through this thing and
there's we use this hl7 this path syntax
of msh is the segment and then three is
the field within that see the sending
app sending facility receiving app
receiving facility the date that the
message came in
i was created the message type here we
have an admit an adt
admit discharge transfer and a01 is an
admin message and then we have a message
id and an hl7 version
and so
i had never seen hl7 when i began this
research i'd heard of it i knew it was
important but i'd never actually seen an
hl7 message and pretty quickly it became
the most important thing in my day and
so early on
we knew it was critically important to
be able to deal with this in water park
so we built an hl7 library and i'm
really proud that hca took that work and
shared it with the community so raising
all boats caring for the community yay
open source and then we have this one
more good reason then for healthcare
companies to use elixir and so and you
can trust this thing works because it is
right now
off in data centers all over it is
chunking through lots and lots of hl7 it
has been for a good long while years
okay
so let's see what this thing let's kick
the tires on this library so we'll say a
message hl7 new and we'll give it some
text that hl7 we're just looking at and
so we get this thing and then we can do
things like querying against it we say
query get part a013.2 and pop we get
aspirin back
and so that shows you kind of what it
looks like you can pull this down play
with it
and
one thing that we use on top of that is
scalable bloom filters and so we'll see
these segments of the papers we love we
we read a lot and we bring a lot of
research and we bring things in and so
scalable bloom filters is one of those
things
so how can we apply this to hl7 so we
have this probabilistic data structure
that has two things on it it lets you
add an item
and it lets you uh see if you've added
that item in the past has it already
been added
and so this probabilistic data structure
doesn't store objects and it doesn't
even store hashes it does a really
memory efficient thing and we can you
can dig into the from the paper from
this book here probabilistic data
structures is really an awesome book
and then but we have these guarantees
we're going to get no false negatives if
we've we won't get a no if we've really
put something into the bloom filter but
we will get false positives and the
scalable bloom filter lets us modify how
much
uh false positive
we can tolerate so we say one percent
and the scalable bloom filter will then
say if you add more more items it'll
just make the bloom filter slightly
bigger as you add more more items
and it'll maintain that one percent
false positive rate so
what would that look like against an
actor so we could say as patient 1000 uh
bloom filter we're going to add that
aspirin that we just searched for a
minute ago and we're going to add it in
the special we're going to clear we're
going to create a string here al1
3.2 colon aspirin
we're going to put the whole path and
the value there we're going to add that
to the bloom filter we're going to add
this diagnosis of unspecified chest pain
and then we're going to have the zip
code for this patient
and we could add all sorts of paths
through this message we go through them
all or we can just add the words to get
full text indexing what we have on the
right and so that's really cool and so
we can then gawk across this patient and
we can walk across all the patients
actually again say an ets table or
something that would have all of the
patients in their bloom filters and
wouldn't even disturb the actors to do
this
but we can hit these bloom filters and
we can say pin seven you have this date
of birth pop yes i have that
birmingham yeah i have that so this
wasn't a path this is just free text
because we'd index that way
and then is member and we asked coppin19
it says false
because when we were doing this work
there was no such thing as covid19
didn't exist and so all of a sudden
those research tools which were very
good in handy those took a back seat to
this other goal here of in three weeks
we need to take waterpark to production
and so
which also meant in three weeks you
never get to take anything down this
thing always has to run forever and ever
from this point forward
and so good thing we've been thinking
about continuous availability from the
beginning and we had our things lined up
and so this means no unplanned outages
and no planned outages
and to get there we followed this idea
from the erlang vm that's really big in
that community in the erlang community
of no masters
so here we have a taos so this is a this
is not a good one by the way this is not
a good pattern that we're looking at
here we have a task router with three
worker nodes problem we have a master up
there if it fails then the workers
aren't going to be doing anything
here have another bad plan worker node
worker node worker node shared storage
fails we have a master you're down
so let's look at
two well let's look at this this is we
have roles in series
so web business logic and database and
you might have heard this called say the
interior architecture
and
also called the worst high availability
plan ever so if any of these things fail
your full system is down because
this problem so given a component that's
three nines of availability
we get 8.8 hours of downtime a year
that's 8.8 hours too many for us and so
if you have in series on the left versus
parallel on the right you get two
different results you get 28
hours or 20 27 26 hours of downtime of
year or you get 32 milliseconds if you
can hit any of these three if any of
them are down you're okay
so we like the option of three
and in parallel rather than series and
what we liked even more than that was
eight
and we liked more than that we like to
divide those into four and four into
availability zones at the data centers
so that if the power failed
at half of the data center our servers
on that side of the data center wouldn't
uh on the other side wouldn't go down
and so it's completely separate networks
completely different power systems and
so we piggybacked on that and had
separation within the data centers so
that we could uh use as much of the
physical separation and the availability
zones there
okay
and we did that at florida tennessee
texas and utah
okay let's talk about process pairs
so process pairs was the technique used
by jim gray in the design default
tolerant tandem computer
and
yeah
and but this uh ends up being one of the
seed ideas in erlang as they were
building erlang out uh and and so this
is one that the joe uh cited and he uh
he talks about earlier but there's a
paper by joe armstrong
[Music]
father of erlang here and basically
saying that to be fault tolerant you
really need to nodes have to be able to
detect if another node's failing it's
crashed
and remember that links and monitors bit
well that's where this comes in this is
one of the ways that comes in and they
should have sufficient data to take over
for a down node
and users should not even notice the
failure so how do we do that on
waterpark
so we have this patient 1001 and it's up
here and it's running in florida a2
we're also going to have a read replica
of that patient running
up on florida
and it's going to have all the data and
it'll take read requests and the writer
will take the right requests but there
it's going to be there in case something
happens we also have a read replica in
tennessee and texas and at utah
and we do this for two reasons one this
lets us survive data center failures
multiple servers across multiple data
centers we can we can
be without losing any data or any
availability
and
it also gives us the cdn quality a
content delivery network so if someone
is doing lots of querying down in utah
they don't have to actually reach out to
florida to pull the data
for those patients that are there they
have a full copy of it locally
and so if that server a2 crashes there
we get a signal about that
and
we just spin up a new writer there
how do we know where that writer goes
how do we know where any of these
readers go how do we know where any of
this stuff lives and so we use server
hash rings
so we're going to new up a hash ring and
we're going to add a bunch of servers to
it
got that and then we can say key to node
actor key 1001.
and after key 1000 node given this hash
ring will always map there every single
request it's always going to go there
okay we use a particular hash ring that
implements rendezvous hashing and so
here's a paper about that you could go
dig in and look at but rhonda hashing
gives us this quality which keeps churn
from happening so given an actor key
1001 each zone assigned a key to a score
and so the server scoring the highest
will own that key
so here we are in s7
and even when other servers drop well
it's still the highest scoring because
nothing changed there right and so
that's that process that actor stays on
that server it doesn't have to move
around reduces a lot of churn now the
things that run s2 and s3 they have to
move because there's no more there's no
longer a server there but all these
other things get to stay there and it
reduces the amount of churn that we have
on the cluster
okay our topology let's take a peek at
that so get our dc's tennessee texas
utah florida
topology get dc ring of tennessee and we
get that
we can say get the current topology
let's get the whole topology here okay
and if we say actor server id and we
give it this facility and this id well
the hospital
x helps us map that to tennessee we're
like oh that's one of those and that
gives us this hash ring and we're able
to come up with tennessee b2
so
we wanted this consistent global
process registry but that was far too
expensive the idea of having consensus
on millions and millions of things that
are changing all the time not going to
happen
so our solution was math
so what we had to do is we just needed
to maintain consensus on topology
and we used that then to route to the
proper local registries which are fast
and cheap
and easy to maintain
and so then we didn't need a global
registry but we still had to do
consensus not on millions of things but
just on one thing and a tiny thing but
it's still not free and not necessarily
easy
so this paper here heidi howard this
distributed consensus revised
points this paxos is widely deployed
[Music]
and so this this is a really useful uh
okay
any luck online
all right well uh
that's a good hands back there so i'll
keep on watching so uh just talked
behind howard at fingerprint uh
two years ago um
[Music]
we actually don't need
[Music]
[Music]
and we realized that we could actually
do better
this value
[Music]
however it works
on the distributing case is how it
should work
so it's a simple powerful idea
and this is one of the key reasons that
waterpark is built on
from
and so to extend this idea of location
transparency from the active level to
the node server level we introduce
an idea called available
okay so waterproof
any node can receive a message
no one outside knows who cares about our
cluster hatchery and registry stuff
they just send things and so each node
has a velcro
and the member who knows
[Music]
inbound messages are routed through the
mailroom with the appropriate patient
and if the patient is remote the mail
remounts the message to the remote
domain
okay if something happened in fly and
that is no longer the same apology and
it's about senate bear
no one's going to reroute that automatic
importance
and it's going to send it over to the
now has instagram accurate message
so this mailroom ideas abstraction
gives us some real super powers one the
top one on here is i think maybe one of
the most important it gives us this
great place
[Music]
i got from joram strong about standing
in variance only let this just sort of
wash over everyone and this will help
you understand why
every patient
has
the facility
of the patient is part
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
before a patient commits an event
[Music]
actor is going to recover from the best
individuals
each patient active state contains
an event
and a map for projections basically the
inferred knowledge the accumulated
knowledge of that patient
so deployments how do we roll things
across the customer so we've
made last 18 months we've had hundreds
of bills deployed
on this thing that never goes down
and so how do we change things
launches and uh servers
go tv releases so our rolling employment
scheme was originally our chaos testing
scheme and so here what we're doing is
we're physically just dropping a note
and then pushing a new build on there
and then bringing it back up it's the
only thing it changed from our chaos
testing because we're pushing view
release out there and it comes up and it
hasn't recovered from the other nodes
and so this is brutal but it keeps us
honest and it's free it doesn't take
back so a full release across the
cluster is about two hour process
okay
and so loading though is a different
animal environment and so this is
something built in early in medium so we
have four modules up here and we have
three processes that are running that
are running both for those four modules
if
the module bounces or we if we push the
new module out there then those
processes in the next external call into
that module into a functional module
reloads
get decoded
okay
so
let's uh let's see what this looks like
we're going to do patches
and it happens in a set like that all
servers
now this is a sharp knife it's powerful
uh it has allowed us to do things we
would not have been able to do another
platform
but it's something we do possibly
another option is dark launcher so we'll
release the big feature we'll send it
out to release but we'll have it turned
off
and then we just basically do
uh
basically just push
[Music]
anyway just push uh
then the config and it updates the uh
the server at that point
okay
and so that that latent feature then
goes into operation and prod okay this
idea i absolutely love and joe here
described this as his favorite erlang
program
and so the idea here is you have a
patient or you haven't not he don't have
a patient actor he didn't he didn't
write healthcare he wrote telecom
and so you had an actor running
and you could say hey actor i'm going to
send you a message and i want you based
on the message to become different
things and so you tell that actor i'm
going to give you the instructions on
how to become an http server or how to
become an ftp server and then that actor
would become that and so this idea
really played into water park this is
what we did in those three weeks
whenever we were told we're about to go
to prod this is what we knew we had to
get in place to support use cases
and so uh covet hit we went to
production we knew we needed a way to
turn the patient actor into a universal
server that could be extended and
changed dynamically at runtime with no
downtime
and so here let's look at our
infinite stream of stuff coming through
and going into our being processed by
our patient actor and then let's look at
this collection of our event handler
plugins our universal server extensions
that hook on here
okay each one of those they have an
interface where like we said earlier in
the in the invariants is they have
projections they take messages they have
the event store and they return new
projections back
so much of this talk so far has been
it's been about the how
and here we're going to talk just a bit
about the why it matters
and so early in the pandemic we deployed
a patient actor plug-in one of these
universal server plugins
to immediately notify facility
caseworkers anytime a patient who had
transferred from a nursing home or from
a long-term care facility tested
positive for covid
so this allowed early contact tracing at
those facilities and quarantines to
reduce the virus spread within these
extremely vulnerable communities
so let's look at our simplified rules of
this plugin that went out
so
was it mission source a nursing home a
long-term care facility
is this a covid19 lab order do we have a
result is the result positive have we
notified a case manager already
and so this is a checklist and so we're
going to walk through here
uh with this checklist and as each
message comes in doing this at the point
that we get all of our checks checked we
know it's then time to act and so this
model based really kind of off the ideas
of atul gawandi and his checklist
manifesto book
here we
we have this set of things this
checklist and we know we're going to
then do something when this happens and
this also becomes a really nice place to
build property-based tests
so these are pure functions each one of
these
becomes a anyway so and at this point we
generate this ltcf alert comes down
is delivered and the case manager we're
going to note that they're informed so
that we can keep on annoying them
telling them the same things happen
they've already contacted the the
facility things are already going to
happen now
and so
my friend and hero joe armstrong
so he passed away in 2019
and
about a year and a half later these
ideas
you know they came in
and you know from beyond the grave this
guy is out there making nursing homes
safer than they would have been
otherwise
so here'd be the takeaways
absorb papers and conference talks
keep ideas in your head and uh
and every time you see new technologies
new ways of applying it you'll be
prepared then in ways you wouldn't have
been otherwise
and um you know find and create work
that's meaningful out there it's um it's
it's easy to spend a career doing work
that doesn't choke you up so
so thanks and and a special thanks to my
team back at hca uh the the developers
the team the whole crew that i work with
they're just absolutely brilliant
and working with them has been the most
fun
meaningful work of my career so big hats
off to them
and so we maybe have a couple of minutes
for questions and uh one other thought
if if this stuff is appealing to you
and you'd like to be a colleague 275 000
plus one uh you know send me an email or
hit me on twitter and follow up with me
because we're always growing and those
other research projects that we were
talking about those have spun off
and we have all sorts of interesting
things outside of waterpark going on and
so
this is a really nice ground to do good
good work so
thanks
so the question was about as you have
multiple versions of the vm this is a
tricky thing to to manage because your
world you have different worlds out
there at the same time and so we have to
do this 3d chess game of of thinking
about on our cluster at any moment how
many versions of the software so not
just versions of erlang but even our
code if we change things we have a
heterogeneous cluster and all these mess
these actors are sending messages back
and forth to each other all the time and
so if we do something we could brick
break it really hard and so so we do
lots of testing we do things with jepson
we do things where we actually spin up
docker clusters where we run multiple
versions of the software at the same
time all these things automated tools
that support that and so you'll want to
do that and so we went through i think
three we went from 22 to 23 to 24. so
we've upgraded erlang three times major
versions uh we've had these hundreds of
bounces uh we've actually had servers
ram catch on fire and you know we've had
all sorts of problems out there and uh
we've kept on churning so
uh and i know we wouldn't have done that
on a different stack
background is uh
for years i was in the microsoft stack
mvp of f-sharp c-sharp and using the
tools i was using back then this
wouldn't have happened and so uh
any other question well actually we're
right at time and so i will not uh ask
you can hit the questions on slack or
hit me on twitter and so on but thank
you all
[Music]
you